how you doing
i'm good how are you
really fantastic uh first of all how
long after you wrap this were you still
finding either a little bits of dried
mud or bee little bits of dried blood
somewhere on your body it's still here
on my fingernails
it looks like you had fun doing it but
it doesn't look like it was fun to do
does that make sense yeah i kind of sums
it up
uh no
it was
i don't know fun is the right word but
it was um
quite a ride it was i was
um
it was definitely
muddy and cold and wet and we shot on
some very remote locations and again
robert edgar's the the director's all
about authenticity so
um
uh there's no
not much comfort up there but
it i i couldn't have imagined doing it
any other way it we wanted an authentic
immersive viking movie and
um how can we expect the audience to be
immersed in that world if we're not
who uh who in the cast really let out
their inner viking that really surprised
you where you were like man they're
going for it they're really getting into
this
not too
pretty i i was i'd say everyone that's
a terrible answer but everyone in front
of and behind camera
was so
going into it everyone knew that it
would be
physically and mentally quite
challenging to shoot this um but but
everyone
really was so motivated and excited to
be there um
and no matter if if if
these big big set pieces were a lot of
waiting around and on days where someone
might not be on camera but everyone was
still there and um
crawling around the mud and and
such team players and it really it it
was an ex
extraordinary experience
i want to talk about your vanity fair um
interview for one second where you
talked about sort of being in that world
of on the hot guys with no shirts list
and sort of getting off of that do you
feel that you are now past that or are
you still in the journey of getting past
that
i haven't read that uh that quote or
that interview but i i i suspect that it
was slightly
misquoted or misunderstood i
um
i was referring to um
when i first started out like
15 20 years ago um
20 years ago
and um how
before in the beginning it was i was
having a hard time
finding work period but but definitely
finding
projects that was or characters that had
any kind of
depth or substance
uh
i i've been incredibly fortunate the
past at least 10
12 years of
of not
feeling
pigeon holed or typecast or on
uh
have been given the most incredible
opportunities and working on different
types of projects and different types of
characters so i um i definitely don't
feel and haven't felt in over a decade
that i'm
stuck somewhere i don't want to be in in
my career
really appreciate it i appreciate your
time uh you this movie is great you are
great in it uh thank you so much man
thank you very much appreciate it you
got it took me
you